pascal drouhaud président de
l'association france amérique latine
bonjour monsieur drouot merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
alors le dauphin d'evo morales et de
l'est largement vainqueur par les
sondages tout juste sorti des urnes les
résultats officiels ne seront connus que
demain la tendance peut-elle encore
s'inverser selon vont parle de 52 4%
écoutez tant que les résultats sont pas
officiels tout est possible mais
clairement luis arce et à très
visiblement emporté les élections
l'écart avec carlos mesa est très grand
il est de plus de 20 points
donc je pense que les résultats à ceux à
ce stade indique une tendance claire et
vont être difficilement contestable tant
mieux tant mieux en effet pour la
démocratie bolivienne qui sort d'une
année extrêmement difficile une année de
tensions politiques depuis le départ de
evo morales parce que je rappelle que
c'est luis arce et kate et du président
de la république
certes au nom du mas le mouvement vers
le socialisme qui avait été créée par
evo morales qui met le nouveau président
et luis arce et qui s'appuie d'ailleurs
sur un colistier david koci banca qui
est l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères mais justement là va être la
difficulté le nouveau pouvoir exécutif
ce n'est pas vraiment à l'aise c'est
naturellement un homme qui a été le
ministre de l'économie de morales
pendant dix ans mais qui pour le coup
vient d'être élu au suffrage universel
est largement élu dans un contexte tout
à fait nouveau parce que je crois que
c'est ça qu'il faut bien noter c'est que
la bolivie de 2020 ce n'est justement
pas d'abou les vies de 2019 il n'y a
qu'une seule année qui s'est écoulé et
pour autant la situation a totalement
évolué notamment de la situation
économique
nous le savons à travers cette crise de
lakovic 19 qui a gagné toute l'amérique
latine
et c'est évidemment propager dans le
monde la rave ou morales qui a félicité
oui car c'est ne s'est pas présenté à sa
propre succession
si son successeur on va dire désignèrent
qui l'aurait emporté comme on vient de
le dire est ce qu'on assiste au retour
de la démocratie comme l'a déclaré luis
arce est justement en tout cas on re on
assiste au retour du processus
démocratique des élections se sont
tenues
elle était annoncée comme extrêmement
tendue polarisée et en fait on voit que
les résultats nets ont montré une
mobilisation et des élections qui se
sont déroulées correctement
visiblement ce que l'on s'en tient à ce
que disent les observateurs qui étaient
présents notamment ceux de l'union
européenne et de lola mais il faut s'en
féliciter la bolivie 1 1 million de
kilomètres carrés c'est un pays
important des andes avec 11 millions
d'habitants c'était 7 millions de
boliviens qui étaient invités aux urnes
hier et qu'il doit absolument sortir
désormais de cette impasse économique
dans laquelle elle est rentrée parce que
la bolivie a été touché de plein fouet
par la crise générée par la copie de
10,9 pourquoi parce que le gros
problèmes économiques de la bolivie
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de diversification
de son économie des ressources
naturelles de sont importantes notamment
évidemment le lithium le fer de cuivre
mais le lithium est constitué des
premières réserves mondiales
sauf qu'il n'y a pas eu d hydrocarbures
évidemment mais il n'y a pas eu de
diversification 80% du pib de la bolivie
provient de ses ressources naturelles et
évidemment quand le cours baisse et
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
eh bien les ressources de la bolivie
baisse autant et ses vins heureusement
l'entrée dans une spirale difficile
alors luis arce s est aussi à l'ancien
ministre de l'économie
un d'evo morales il est considéré par
beaucoup comme le père du miracle
économique bolivien pourquoi exactement
mais c'est ce qu'il est il a été
ministre de l'économie de 2006 à 2010
est
c'est à cette époque il ya eu un boom
économique parce que les ressources
naturelles avait des cours extrêmement
important et que ça a permis au pouvoir
bolivien de redistribuer les dividendes
je vais dire de ces ressources est
naturellement de faire baisser notamment
le taux de pauvreté mais c'est ce que je
vous disais en introduction la donne a
changé
nous ne sommes plus en 2017 nous sommes
en 2020 entre temps la halle a commis
dix neuf est passée par là la crise
économique est forte en bolivie où il ya
un ralentissement comme un peu partout
économique une dérive des déficits
publics une hausse du chômage désormais
à 10% de la population dans un pays où
près de 60 % travaillent dans l'économie
informelle
donc les défis pour luis arce et sont de
taille
son expérience de ministre de l'économie
et bien ventes vont être extrêmement
utile désormais parce que la bolivie de
2020 c'est une bolivie qui doit relancer
son économie dans un environnement
régional incertain je vous rappelle que
la bolivie a des frontières avec le
brésil le pérou le chili le paraguay et
l'argentine
autant de pays qui doivent désormais
essayer de travailler ensemble
ça ne sera pas facile merci beaucoup
pascal drouhaud d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je vous rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'association france
amérique latine